[heavy breathing]
[groans]
[groans] N-No...
Th-This is wrong...
We-- We shouldn't be... here.
[screaming]
[screaming continues]
[grunts]
[sustained high-pitched tone]
Where are you?!
[roaring, whooshing]
[noises subside]
[crickets chirping]
[thunderous stomping]
Are you still here?!
[whooshing]
[whooshing increases]
[gasping]
[gasping, panting]
[thunder crashes]
-[thunder crashing]
-[whirring]
[whirring increases]
[whooshing]
Please!
Tell me where you are!
[clattering sounds]
[doors clanks]
Take my hand!
Please!
[whooshing increases]
[sustained buzzing sound]
[silence]
[gasping, panting]
[panting slows]
[sighing heavily]
Oh, God.
I'm sure there must have been a time
when I had nice dreams.
[sighs] Maybe when
I lived in palaces and mansions?
But maybe not.
That was all stress.
Doing my little dance for coins,
making sure I had enough for the next...
[sighs] month, the next year.
Never bloody easy, was it?
[snaps fingers]
And then...
there was you.
Did I dream when you were here?
I don't know.
I was too focused on our daylight hours.
I never wanted to sleep in those days.
And now here I am again.
Never wanting to sleep.
Not until I find you.
Not until I live
in the good dream again.
[pen scratching on paper]
Not until you're back.